i've written a column for the sun
tonight about prince charles
i keep saying this everyone does don't
they uh king charles iii
about i've rarely seen any public figure
rise to such momentous occasion i don't
think in the way that he does
and as always you write a column like
that and it certainly it will stand the
test of time but there was a moment
today which i think just showed that
underneath this exterior which he's
putting on
is a man that's just lost his the mother
he loved coming so soon after the father
that he loved under enormous pressure to
hit the right tone and hit it running as
our new monarch and there was this
moment where he went to sign
an official document today with his ink
pen and this is how he reacted
to 12 13
oh god
thirteen yes
is
[Music]
i mean this is for cbs news this footage
i mean i was surprised that we get to
see that actually i think he should have
been better protected but it was an
insight just into behind the the veneer
is a man who's under enormous pressure
both personally and professionally well
yesterday i was privileged to be in
westminster hall that was just being
spoken about this 900 year old hall one
of the oldest parts of this country i
mean along with windsor castle and the
tower of london uh you have westminster
and westminster abbey these are the
ancient parts of our country and he
spoke about that and how much it meant
to him and with all of us lords and
members of parliament over there and you
could see
how moved he was and actually i saw a
photograph today which showed that he
was in tears
during during that occasion but emily
that little snapshot there of him you're
losing his temper about a 40 pen
i just thought it just showed us that
beneath all this
there must be a torrent of emotions
raging inside this new king
i'm sure because he's he's probably also
exhausted
um what i was interested to get more
detail on today which was george bush's
daughter was over to interview him
um sorry was interview over here to
interview the new queen consort and
clearly they were not expecting the
queen to pass away where my reading had
slightly been that because
our king had been with her all week that
they were concerns i think this really
did come as a shock i don't think
they're expected so he will also be
suffering still from the shock and you
don't i imagine the amount that he's
having to deal with and present himself
the speech is becoming king i doubt he's
had any time to i i don't like using the
word process but in a way as you see
he's not properly agreed
they haven't had much and i am surprised
the world's cameras adam aren't they
they're focused on this man
now and his his wife camilla
relentlessly from the second they appear
in public and they're having to appear
in public all the time whilst going
through what i would imagine is pretty
intense grief well i i agree with that
but on the other hand the reason why the
world's cameras are there is because
as the queen said you need to be seen
that these rituals that they're going
through visiting
uh the four nations of the country are
important in terms of establishing the
monikers uh the head of state uh of all
the united kingdom and you know
i'm afraid my reaction looking at that
footage
and i know
all the pressures that you've mentioned
and all the
undoubted genuine grief is my reaction
is the queen wouldn't have behaved like
that right and she
she would have made a joke of it and
well and she probably wouldn't have
actually had that happen in front of a
camera i mean that's the thing i'm
surprised that well it's not better than
these signing
ceremonies
are part of the whole deal i mean that's
that's why they're taking place i mean
we saw i don't know whether lord bill
and moria was there but at the session
ceremony everyone who was there yes
signed a document in public and quite a
lot only cbs cameras were capturing that
moment and i'm just surprised we've been
able to see it because it does show a
moment away from what we're seeing i
mean he loses but i mean i'm afraid i do
think these
these instances these off-camera moments
can be quite revealing yeah
there's this issue about how far do you
go to show the queen
respect
in cancelling things there's been a
whole
slew of things cancelled the football
was all cancelled at the weekend but the
cricket the racing the golf all went on
and showed a respectful moment of
silence and applause and then moved on
which i felt was the right way to handle
it um what do you think about this
center parks today for example
have suddenly decided they're gonna stop
everything on monday on the day of the
funeral and remove every family who's on
holiday there and tell them they're
gonna leave which seems to me completely
outrageous and the very last thing
that her majesty would have wanted
what has happened over here is you've
got a figure
that
has sort of risen above all other people
in the world in many ways for 70 years
and you've got this individual's monarch
of all monarchs the queen of all queens
that is not just the most famous monarch
in the world but the most respected i
mean i've received messages from every
corner of the world you think that
were right so i know i'm saying that
people that if you look at look at the
sentiment that people are expressing
look at the people started queueing to
pay respects in westminster hall from
yesterday i remember yesterday when i
went to swear my oath i was told one of
the peer centers people are starting but
when you have a massive holiday company
with a load of people who pay good money
and they're told they have to leave all
these parks around the country i think
that is a ridiculous way of supposedly
showing the queen i think what you're
seeing is is
companies
frankly using is a bit of an excuse i
mean i've had two of those you know
those things when you phone up you get a
recorded message two of them saying oh
we can't get your message today because
of the circumstances and you know we
know people i think it was in norwich
uh closed bicycle parking spaces as well
food banks in wimbledon are being closed
on monday yeah and that caused outrage
people saying let me get this straight
we're going to be
shutting down food banks for the most
desperate hungry people in the country
whilst at the same time the reason given
is because there's a funeral for one of
the riches the only thing i would say
and i don't know whether quite how it
works out but
rightly it's been called a bank holiday
on monday
a day for everyone to show their respect
and i think some companies may have
contractual things with their employees
about them not being there at bank
holidays and all that kind of maybe not
wanting to be accused of not allowing
their employees to mourn their queen
emily i want to talk to you about um
princess anne he put out a statement uh
just before we came on air saying how
fortunate she failed to share the last
24 hours of my dearest mother's life
it's been an honour and a privilege to
accompany her on her final journeys
witnessing the love and respect shown by
so many omnicho has been both humbling
and uplifting we will all share unique
memories offer my thanks to each and
every one who shares our sense of loss
and she then goes on to say that um she
offers very grateful for the support and
understanding of her dear brother
charles as he accepts the added
responsibilities of the monarch to my
mother the queen thank you i i do think
in many ways ann is the most like her
mother of all the other royals actually
and watching her following her mother's
hearts all around the country has been
incredibly moving i i find just watching
incredibly moving i think if you hear
anyone talking about the royals ann is
the unsung heroine she's the hardest
working royal the least celebrity she's
the least celebrity she works the
hardest she doesn't chase the media
she's never got caught in any kind of
scandal um i mean there may have been
some when she was incredibly young but
it's
been a few no one marriage now there's a
second i mean and her children are
exemplary so i think a lot of a lot of
people have a huge amount of affection
for princess anne she's she's i mean
again i've been again lucky and
privileged to see this firsthand and her
her private secretary who retired
recently he always used to have got the
hardest working boss in the world yeah
and it was real she worked really well
her title the princess royal was
recognition really funny i just don't
think she ever gets the attention that a
lot of the other royals get and she
should get more attention i think she's
not sure